Y aquí estamos los chichicos, y empezaremos la clase de hoy.
Hoy vamos a pasar una hora por cuestiones de salud.
No va a ser tan complicado la clase, pero va a ser bastante interesante lo que vamos a saber.
No se preocupa en esa parte.
Voy a admitir algunas personas más y ahora empezamos.
Ya, ya lo iniciaremos. Hoy sí va a haber una pequeña evaluación, así que vamos a abrir un borte.
Voy a abrir el borte, va a ser el trabajo número 6, si no me equivoco.
Igual es lo mismo.
Voy a seleccionar 4 personas al azar para mostrarles el día.
Aquí lo mismo nombre que pasó Patricia.
Buenas noches.
¿Cuál es el proyecto que tenemos que proponer?
Voy a trabajar con visión artificial para los créditos de carbono en la agricultura.
Me pregunta, alguna de las clases recomiendo que podríamos comprar un paquete de 5 dólares.
¿Qué opinas de hacer estos análisis con visión artificial?
Voy a ir comprando paquetes, quería saber qué recomendaciones me da a usted.
¿Qué vas a entrenar?
Imágenes satelitales. Voy a trabajar con regiones de Santa Cruz.
Bueno, así resumiendo, porque no lo tengo todavía, como tenía que dar más o menos la estructura.
La consulta, la automatización, como tal, va a ser también que se pongan las coordenadas de su área o el archivo en cada DMZ
y que les dé una respuesta más o menos de ciertos índices.
Exacto, ya, es lo que te recomiendo, siguiente.
Para esa parte no es necesario utilizar, pero es utilizar netamente websockets.
Websockets directamente te trabaja con el sistema.
Esto trabaja de manera paralela.
Tú la consultas la posición, él te entrega y viceversa.
Cuando él te entrega te va a decir, ah, ya, eso está actualizando.
O sea, se actualiza el tiempo actual.
No necesitas una idea, porque esto lo vas a seguir directamente con los parámetros y con las interfaz que vas a conectarlos.
Así que no es necesario.
Para entrenar netamente esto, si lo vas a utilizar, supongo en call-up o en Piedorch, no sé cuál, pero no necesitas.
A no ser que tú le preguntes, ah, ya, ¿quieren esta coordenada tal proceso o tal análisis?
A todos los parámetros estadísticos y sensidades que manejas, ah, y así puedes utilizar para hacerte menos, menos extenso tu proyecto y menos pesado.
Pero, para lo que me comentas, no es más que pueda trabajar sin IASO, esa parte.
¿Eso podría ser válido para que también lo presente acá?
No, no hay problema.
No hay problema, no sé si, ¿listo?
¿Listo, Valeria?
Gracias.
¿Listo?
Pero sí. Continuaremos entonces.
Y, igual con lo que no hay su nombre, su la fecha de IASO, la evaluación número 6, creo.
Valeró 6, sí, sí, la evaluación 6.
Valeró 6, número 6.
Ok, continuamos.
Captura 1.
Ya, y un buen punto que tocó su compañero.
O eso lo voy a hablar cuando ya termine de hacer este proceso.
Ahí vamos a aplicarlo.
Ya, algunos cosillas, además.
Yo voy a hacer compaseros de pago.
O sea, de este módulo no va a hacer compaseros de pago, pero le voy a dar una idea de cómo hacerlo.
Eh, listo.
Aprobre, de muy poquito.
¿Inicializaremos en H&M?
Listo.
Voy a esperamos un rato y ahorita voy a indicar los que vamos a ver.
Ahora sí.
A ver, voy a ver si está.
Se que iniciando.
No sé qué. Esperamos un rato.
El road truck inisero, porque la verdad es que es ordenado 6 weeks.
Listo, listo, listo.
Bueno, hasta que vaya habilitando, ¿sí?
Te voy a dar unas ideas.
Valería.
Soy Patricia.
No, Patricia, perdón, Patricia.
Siempre me confunden con nombres.
En Zacarias.
Aquí dice dole a Zacarias.
Una vez que entres ahí, lo descargas.
Bueno, esto es.
Hay la parte comienta, por eso.
Ahí está el dole, lo descargas.
Lo bueno de esto es que,
si no tienes que hacer un rato,
lo bueno de esto es que,
el rango que maneja es bastante preciso.
Demasiado.
Varia por medio metro.
Ahora la otra cuestionante,
lo siguiente.
Todo esto maneja, netamente, con boards.
Boards, se hace se llama GS.
Boards, Boards System, dice un otro.
Esto.
Es un geo server.
Un geo server es como,
como se te dijera,
todos los datos que estás consultando,
directamente aquí server,
en una base de datos.
Esa base de datos ya consultas.
Las posiciones, tiempos.
Por ejemplo, yo esto trabajo con la empresa de Uber.
Yo se los gestiono los datos
para posicionamiento.
Y ahí lo trabajo con ellos,
pero ya, ellos se han quedado con ese software.
Y ya, pues, problemas se van a decir
y se van a autorizarlo.
Pero esa parte.
Listo.
Eso es bueno.
Y eso lo enlace con Poges,
PQDS, Python, NCHN.
Y listo.
Es larga el proceso.
Es que no, pero es interesante.
Y para algunos eventos que tienes problemas
aquí, estas sus suportes.
Cómo se aplica un suporte,
cómo puedes cargren code,
se avisa todo.
¿Qué modelos existen?
No.
Te recomiendo que siempre trabajes con los M5s
y con lo que es 3.4.6.
Los demás son medvinas tablas.
Esto es lo más estable de Poges.
Otro frame que puedes utilizar si pareces a nivel Pro,
tu sistema, yo lo meto con Larabel.
Larabel, Poges, QDS, Python, NCHN.
Y listo.
Ya funciona.
Es mayor lo que dice más en aplicaciones que
en sistemas webs.
Pero es interesante.
Listo.
Lo que he abierto.
A ver si continuamos.
Ah, perdón.
Refresco y tu es 0.
Ya.
Listo.
Voy entre mi workflow.
Y ahora si,
trabajar en mucho chico.
Yo ya me he adelantado.
Así que voy a ser de 0 de estas.
Estaba probando mis días.
Para que no perdiera tiempo y estar conectando cada rato.
Así que me refiero un poquito de adelantar.
Pero voy a ser con ustedes de 0.
Así que ese webhook lo voy a borrar.
De ustedes ya estaba así.
Ya voy a continuar.
Webhook.
Listo.
Lo jalo.
Esto lo voy a jalar acá.
Ya.
Ahora si.
A partir de acá es un poquito interesante las cosas.
Porque a partir de acá es más real su proyecto.
Y a partir de acá ya pueden hacer lo que ustedes quieren.
Ya los 100 clásico le vamos a hacer algo más complejo.
Y supongo que vamos a pasar unos 8 cosas más.
Y va a morirlos.
Se comentó anteriormente.
Ya nos queda mucho tiempo.
Y a lo demás es más más cosa avanzada de programación.
Que se acro que lo vamos a hacer en un módulo 2.
No sé cómo queden internamente.
Voy a consultar esa parte.
Así que vayas como se vea indicado.
Vayan abriendo base code.
Esto es opcional chicos.
Yo lo voy a hacer para darles algún contexto más.
Pero es opcional.
No necesito que se lo manejen.
Pero en este caso vamos a hacer lo siguiente.
Voy a abrir una nueva carpeta.
Dentro de esa carpeta vayas a hacer lo siguiente.
Crean que es una carpeta ahorita misma.
Muy aparte.
Voy a crear un mayor.
Por este caso en programación.
Y vamos a crear lo que.
Y a proyectos en 8 n.
Proyectos.
Proyectos en 8 n.
Listo. Entran ahí.
Vienen acá y van a colocar una carpeta.
Bueno decirle.
No sé.
Proyecto 1.
Pro 1.
O Pro 1.
Listo.
Hasta ahí.
De mi pecho.
Actíbarme.
Y sistema.
Ahora sí.
Ya.
Una vez que dentro de ahí.
Van a hacer clic derecho.
Abren terminal.
Abren la terminal.
Y van a hacer lo siguiente.
Ya.
Van a colocar en este caso.
Code.
O sea,
en minúsculo de mallos,
code espacio.
Y apretan enter.
Listo.
Apretan enter.
Y nos va a modificar el sistema.
Una vez que los modifique.
Ahí todos esperan.
Les va a habilitar esta cosa.
Ya.
Automáticamente les va a abrir.
Una vez que ya lo han abierto automáticamente.
Voy a ingresar aquí.
Esto es una.
Los voy a hacer un poquito de programación.
Obviamente no he hecho en este modo lo nuevo.
O sea,
mucha programación.
Lo que se me ha dedicado a hacerlo de manera directa.
Pero.
Siempre es bueno que conozcan los que no conocen esta parte.
Una vez que ya han abierto esa parte.
Voy a apretar la tecla.
Contrón.
Y se va a habilitar esto.
Ya.
Abreta en control.
Y voy a usarme.
A ese proyecto.
Este.
Qué creado.
Entrar el CD y para salir de CD.
C.
CD pro y.
Uno.
Y listo.
Y se va a entrar.
Se dan cuenta de si quiero salir de ese.
C.
Y se sal.
Entrar el CD.
Pro.
Así es.
Ya.
Esa parte pueden hacer.
Sus comandos.
Si es que no quieren manejar esto.
Se llama.
Comand prompt.
Bien.
Acá.
Entre acá.
Y coloquen en este caso.
Y.
O pueden colocar.
Lo que los voy a decir ahorita.
Pero todavía no quiero que lo haga.
Esta parte conozcan hoy listo.
Ya.
Ahora voy a trabajar con web hooks.
Anotamente compuro web hooks.
Hoy día.
Hasta cierto punto.
Ya.
Voy a abrirme en este caso el proyecto.
Voy a abrirme chat y piti.
O cualquier ida que ustedes quieran.
Ver.
Ya.
Y le voy a dar un prompt correspondiente.
Ojo.
Esto lo van a hacer ustedes independientemente.
No quiero que los repitan lo mismo que yo.
Pero si algunos prompts que yo voy a hacer.
Y.
Esto en base a que.
Esto va a hacerlo en base a lo que son sus proyectos.
Por ejemplo.
En este caso.
Mi proyecto era acá.
Era en este caso.
La voy a ensercar.
Submission.
Era de Uriacilo.
Vente de fertilizantes.
Ya.
Eso voy a mantener.
Y nos voy a darle prompt en base a su.
Vengo acá a mi chatito GPT.
Y voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Voy a darle prompt.
Voy a decir.
Necesito.
Hagan lo mismo conmigo.
Pero embasa ustedes.
Con sus proyectos que están lo haciendo.
Ya.
Necesito una página.
Web.
Con.
Chowlin.
Vale a decir.
Chow.
Chowlin.
Ya.
Cs.
Html.
Y van a colocarle.
Esto se llama por ser caso.
Esto es interesante.
Cuando son páginas web sencillas.
Se llaman los landing page.
Ya.
Y vamos a hacer un landing page.
Y luego vamos a volver al sistema.
El cual voy a colocar.
El cual debe detener.
Tres secciones.
Ya.
Y esa parte siempre es bueno colocarla con mayúsculo.
Lo que me termina es.
La parte primera es inicio.
Inicio.
Coma.
Servicios.
Contactos.
O contacto.
Listo.
Ya.
Ahora.
Punto.
Van a colocar.
Lo siguiente.
Ahora si coloquen el contexto de su empresa.
Yo voy a decir.
Somos.
Una empresa.
Que vende.
Productos.
Destinados.
Al ámbito.
Del fertilizante.
Fertilizantes.
Es.
Ya.
Voy a colocar en la página.
En la página.
De contacto.
Y.
Ya.
De contacto.
Y.
Punto.
Html.
Así es.
Si tienen que colocar ustedes.
Necesito.
Enviar.
4.
Campos.
Ya.
Esto.
Esto va a tener que tener cuidado.
Ya.
Porque esta parte es muy dependiente de los campos que usted está manejando.
Por ejemplo acá.
En web.
Hux.
En.
Y.
De contacto.
De contacto, ¿no?
Eshou.
Hay.
P disparando.
Estada capturando.
nombre.
E-mail.
Cellular.
celular
celular y van a colocar en este caso un mensaje de cliente
ya, voy a hacer uno a propósito lo voy a errar
digamos que es 4 parámetros digamos que es 4, voy a ir a recocatriz, me olvidé, me voy a
asesorar, no me he notado y listo, voy a crear eso, ahora te van a ver cómo voy a modificar el sistema
luego en este caso lo cierro y voy a colocar esa información
se debe enviar
por el método post, se van a colocar el mayúsculo, ya, a la url, dos puntos, ahora van a hacer lo siguiente
vienen a la parte de su webhook, o acá
y van a enchar acá, doble clic
esto ahorita está en el método get, van a cambiar la post
y van a copiarse esto, ya, los abuelen, estamos ahorita en testing, luego vamos a producción
y le van a pegar esto
ya
y bueno, con la coma, dame los tres archivos
archivos
html
listo
hasta ahí, por si acaso al ultimo siempre le van a añadir
as o realiza
realiza un diseño atractivo
listo, ya está, enter, viveremos con webhook
game está botando el index
y los servicios
y el contacto
listo
como ya no abierto todo esto, van a hacer lo siguiente, van a copiarse el código, pero puede antes de
descagar y demás, pueden ver cómo se ve, la voy a ver acá, fíjense, no se ve mucho
lo que es la parte del ccs, así que ahorita lo voy a decir de nuevo que lo corrijo,
eso puede ser veanlo antes, a veces no lo crea, añade, sigue, sigue, sigue, cada archivo
listo
ya ahora sí, ya me he añadido
pero en este caso lo voy a decir, si es que les molesta, sigue, en conjunto, dame completo,
pero aquí ya pueden ver cuál es su estilo más o menos, ya pueden decirle dame
el código completo, listo, y ahora sí los voy a añadir los tres
en versión básica
listo
ya la cuestión que tenga estilos, o sea, y incluso le pueden colocar que sea para celular,
digamos, ya que sea responsivo, saliendo eso, ya medio que algo ha mejorado, pero esta ya no
me sirve, a ustedes no debe funcionar, yo voy a copiar la misma a otra ida,
ya abragan pruebas, ahí y vayan viendo qué les conviene, que es más bonito, que es menos bonito,
ya voy a abrir otro, otra ida, voy a tratar de manejar con Groco, DeepSick,
y vamos a ver cómo me da DeepSick, la parte donde está DeepSick,
ahora sí, voy naciendo las mejores ies, y la mejor mejor es la cláutela en formato estético,
pero aquí me pide número de teléfono, vamos a iniciar la sensación,
yémini también pueden hacer pruebas, se van haciendo pruebas, y esa captura que saquen,
lo van a añadir como se puede poner a captura, ya eso van a añadirlo hasta ahí,
de mancacho, voy a ver donde está mi yémini, esto aquí está por ejemplo,
voy a utilizar el mismo prompt acá, y vamos a ver qué me bota,
listo,
ya y voy a abrir otro más,
ahí me da,
me da servicios,
y me da contacto, pero no yémini creo que no se puede, se puede descargar el archivo directo,
ya pero como ya no quiero, bueno ustedes pueden descargar, no hay problema,
yo lo voy a hacer como estamos trabajando acá, voy a hacer control C, tengo acá,
dentro del proyecto voy a colocar index, listo, ahora lo voy a pegar el prompt,
y esto copio, ustedes más o menos se lo pueden descargar y llevarlo a esa carpeta más rápido,
ya quiero ver antes cómo va a salir, de mi pechita, listo, voy a ver cómo va a salir,
ya, me de que miren, bastante bonito,
yo lo he hecho,
ustedes pueden para hacer esto, pueden ustedes, y dos veces hacen clic en la carpetita aquí,
proyecto, ahí haciendo double click y la suavirita, miren, listo, eso pueden hacerlo,
igual, igual da, ya, voy a copiármelo los demás, voy a descargarlo para el nuestro copiéndolo,
voy a pegar directamente la carpeta, lo descargo y lo descargo, ya vean ustedes la mejor apariencia,
voy a abrir esa carpeta, me descargas, ya, y listo, voy a control X y lo voy a pegar a mi
sistema, ya danse los proyectos, programación, proyectos en 8n, proyectos y aquí lo voy a pegar,
listo, ya está, lo que aquí van a modificar es el nombre, es el nombre, si es lo malo,
hay veces de diferencia, ya tienen sus propios, cómo trabajan, ya, este es contacto 8n,
le supongo que es el otro, ahora voy a abrir, es el segundo que se ha abritado, este es el
07, es el contacto, ya vengo acá y aquí se va a hacer los 07, este es lo que es contacto,
no sé si me estoy equivocando, no, contacto 8n, y el otro debe ser servicio, así que lo mismo,
este es mi chachito, voy a hacer el otro, y danse el otro, aquí este van a,
esto lo voy a hacer rápido, no confundirme y voy a meter el otro, el contacto y el otro,
traten de manejarse y con los datos que les da, si no, se va a tener problemas,
es servicio, se hace control, rename y listo,
ya está, ahora sí, voy a actualizar lo que hecho correr, donde estaba lo que hecho correr,
aquí está, esto lo voy a hacer raro, bueno se va a conocer cómo se va a dar este repuesto
y aquí voy a actualizar, voy a ver si es contacto siempre, a ver, y voy a irme a servicios,
ahí está, y voy a irme a contactos, ahí está, ya,
y eso que me lo ha creado, teléfono y contacto más, ya, listo, ahora supuestamente al momento de
enviar el mensaje ese dedo, se está linkando con la web el correspondiente, ya así que haremos
la prueba, hasta ahí, hasta aquí ustedes deberían de sacar o tienen que sacar chicos su primera captura,
ya en base a su proyecto por su caso, ahí, y listo,
y la captura 1, captura 2 ahora,
listo, voy a verificar yo si es que tiene el código correspondiente de contacto,
ya supuestamente sí me está enviado, pero si hay algunos problemas hay que revisar el código,
pero cómo está el curso, no es el código, aquí está, mira,
this form reaction, aquí me está enviando justamente al mismo link que estoy enviando
yo anteriormente, acá, a mi webhook, ya, ahí está mi link, nada más, eso verifican si está,
porque hay algunas ideas medio que raras, no es en caso, por ejemplo a mí no me hace caso
dipsick, así que esa parte, ya, lo demás lo dejan por defecto, y lo cierran,
ahora sí, haremos prueba, voy a dividir mi pantallita entre dos,
y haremos prueba de esa parte, y esto es su segunda captura, pero cuál es todavía, voy a acomodar,
listo, ahí,
ya, ahí digamos, ok, empezaremos, voy a minimizar esto un poco más,
ahora sí, para que funcione esto tienen que colocar lo siguiente,
ahí, ejécuten el workflow,
hay que esperar un cacho, si no les reacciona al principio, vuelven a actualizar, ya,
en este caso está bugueando salmío, porque a eso estaba dando clases con IAS, y se me
complicó todo mis dependencias, voy a actualizarlo y voy a volverlo a ver, ya, listo,
ya, ahora voy a abrir un cacho, y, y para que esto pase,
ya, listo, muy lento, esto, pues mi intervalo es una cosa,
ya, ya, estoy muy acercado, estoy muy excedido, ya, voy a reiniciar creo, ya,
esto no ocurre, porque le activó ahí el visual, o nada que ve, no, nada que, porque este es muy
independiente, si, porque no solamente estoy habiendo una URL para que le escuches, ahorita no estoy,
no se preocupan esa parte.
Ya, el mío es porque tengo un montón de dependencias que he activado
y no inicia mi componso en bien su...
listo.
Ya.
Si no nos voy a reiniciar esto.
¡Maya!
Ahora, antes de trabajar con los edificios,
yo solo necesito que este me escuche, nada más, ya.
¿Arién quería hablar, creo?
Sí, creo que debe de aquí ver el engrro en el localhost para que te acuche.
Ah, sí, eso luego lo vamos a hacer cuando sea de producción.
Ahorita debería de...
darme.
Esto, por si caso, trabaja sin engroc.
Si es local, solamente le voy a reloj a escuchar.
Ya, así que...
listo, vamos a decir.
Ok.
Voy a activar algunas cosas.
Listo.
Ya.
Mmm-hmm-hmm-hmm-hmm.
A ver, esperamos un cacho, si no aparece siempre,
voy a tener que hacer lo siguiente.
Ya.
Voy a reiniciar el engrro en el chón.
Voy a hacer lo resto, voy a abrirlo de esta forma para que no tenga problemas.
Está, está, está, listo.
Para irme acá.
Voy a irme a contacto directamente.
Y listo, ahí vamos a hacer...
esto lo voy a dejar acá.
Listo.
Ya, si no se van a esperar un tiempo, ya.
Ustedes, si los da super.
Porque no había estado en un lío mis...
mis...
versiones.
Ahora, te trabajamos para la noche, ya, si me ha fregado todo el sistema.
Listo, voy a cerrarlo y voy a abrirlo de la huya.
Ustedes, vayan haciendo lo más.
Vayan viendo y vayan capturando sus pantallas y así de más.
Ah, yo estoy con el entorno Linux más.
Todo me está fregado.
De mancacho.
Y listo.
Ya.
De mancacho voy a desactivar mi Linux.
Tata, tata, tata.
Si, no se va a haber problemas.
Vuelto, vuelto a saber.
Vuelto a saber.
Si, se va a ver.
Ya, ahora si.
Ya voy a cerrarlo.
Vuelto a saber.
Ya.
Viento, voy a esperar.
Tata, tata, tata.
Que más, nada más.
Bueno, mientras tanto les explicaré un poquito de webhooks,
pero a nivel un poquito más avanzado.
No voy a entrar mucho en detalle de algunos aspectos más técnicos,
pero eso para entonces en un segundo módulo más o menos es que existen.
Pero voy a trabajar ahorita con pasadas de pago, digamos.
Así que voy a ver acá.
Scaledro.
Diez miles, va veritando esa parte.
Aprovecharemos en el avance al trabajo de teoría.
Ya.
Listo.
Generalmente lo que son los webhooks,
pero ahora voy a hacer en dos ámbitos aplicativos.
Voy a trabajar más que todo en banca.
Y voy a trabajar también en la parte de inteligencia artificiales,
pero no las básicas.
Por ejemplo las deekoms.
Deekoms ahí.
Son los deekoms que trabajamos ahí.
Ya.
Qué diferencia hay.
Cómo trabajan los webhooks.
Generalmente cuando yo trabajo con banca.
Ehh, en es sinceramente el cuervo.
Bueno, en Bolivia,
lamentablemente los bancos no tienen una actualización de sus sistemas internos.
Por eso hay veces complicado que hagamos pasadas de pago con paypal o con otras empresas,
porque no están todavía automatizadas.
Y pero en Bolivia existe netamente lo que son los queries por defecto.
Eso los tienen en varias bancas, que en este caso puede ser la BNB.
La BNB tiene Básica y la Mercantil.
Las dos son las únicas que en Bolivia tienen cueres tramitables.
Es decir, que los cueres puedan utilizarse con webhooks.
Ya.
Las demás bancos no tienen.
Los ciencias están actualizando y manejan un montón de parámetros.
Entonces necesariamente cuando yo hablo de un webhook,
le estoy dando una dirección, o sea, un HTTP.
Si es un HTTP o un HTTP es.
Cuando accede desde el cuero, esto me recepciona.
Me recepciona inmediatamente y me valida.
Ahora dentro de los cueres sabemos que existe encriptaciones.
Dentro de estas encriptaciones hay donde dentro en términos webhooks.
Pero estos webhooks ya no se llaman webhooks normales,
se llaman webhooks antinaturales.
Los webhooks antinaturales me generan aleatoriedades
en mis sistemas patrones de mis contraseñas.
O sea, lo hashé.
Para los que no entienden esa parte,
hashé es como encriptar la contraseña que tengo.
Pero aquí se llaman los webhooks.
Los webhooks se llaman.
Los webhooks o los webhooks se llaman.
Es bien raro esos nombres, ¿no?
Pero tienen esos dos nombres.
Una vez que los webhooks entran en proceso,
lo recién es tu valida.
Y ahora en un N8N si se puede implementar.
No es que no.
Tiene procesos internos que se puede trabajar.
Ahora los d-comps.
O sea, lo estoy explicando ahorita.
¿Dónde mayormente existe este tipo de webhooks?
Ya, de mucho.
Ahora sí, voy a abrir esto.
Y haremos la prueba correspondiente.
Ya.
Y si me da error,
se va a tener que renunciar porque he dejado de...
No sé si se han dado cuenta,
pero miren acá.
Mi sistema está vulnerable ahorita.
Porque...
Le he deshabilitado todo en mis paquetes para crearme entornos.
Así que ahorita está en modo hackeable.
Así que esa parte voy a ahorita verlo.
Por eso no me está dejando algunos punts.
Tengo que activarlos desde mi bio.
Si no, siempre voy a poder trabajar con ustedes.
Ya.
Listo.
Una vez más voy a hacer...
Sí.
Tengo que desactivarles.
Ya, chics.
Voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Vamos a trabajar de manera aleatoria.
Voy a desactivar eso.
Lo malo que voy a demorar un poquito tiempo.
Listo.
Ahora sí.
Lo voy a abrir desde acá.
Ya.
Ya lo he activado.
Esperemos que funcione.
Una vez que estoy escuchando...
Ahora sí.
Dividanlo entre dos pantallas.
Y mandenlo.
Voy a abrir esto donde estaba esa cosa.
Donde estaba, donde estaba, donde estaba.
Acá está.
Ya voy a abrir de nuevo.
Si no, ya abran su contacto.
Ahora sí.
Abranse esto.
Muy aparte.
Y ahora sí, envíenlo.
Ya envíenlo.
Tiene que estar escuchando eso.
Listo.
Ahí voy a colocarlo.
Y voy a dividirlo en dos pantallas.
Listo.
Esa captura me van a sacar ustedes.
Ahora sí.
Ya.
Colocaremos en este caso...
Coloquen un correo que realmente están utilizando.
Y sea verdadero.
Para que les vote todo eso.
Ahora voy a colocar milton, blanco.
Tata, tata, tata. Listo.
732.
Y listo.
Quiero productos de venta para fertilizantes.
Listo.
Colocan en vía.
Y ha escuchado.
Miren.
Ha escuchado.
Ahí está.
Ya ha capturado esos datos.
Milton.
Tantos, tantos.
Quiero venta para fertilizantes.
Esto que sea su siguiente captura.
Ya.
Listo.
Vienen a su word.
Y lo pegan a la siguiente captura.
Ya.
Ahora sí.
Pero si lo cierro esto, van a fijar solo.
Está el bucle.
Pero mi modelo ya está pensando.
Y ya me está enviando el correo.
No sé qué me he enviado.
Pero van a ver cuál es la diferencia.
Ya.
Ahora sí.
Voy a entrar en mi correo.
Ya.
De un coche.
Os voy a mostrar cómo es mi correo personal.
Lo voy a ocultar ya.
Un coche.
Tengo un montón de datos ahí.
Capazes más ustedes son hackers.
Hay que siempre ver.
Ya.
Listo.
Y justo me he enviado.
Pero me he enviado cualquier cosa.
Miren.
Y ya.
¿Qué es lo que es?
¿Qué?
Miren.
Bueno, me he enviado lo que...
No me he dado el nombre.
No voy a hablar solamente...
Me he enviado.
Ha hecho lo que tiene que hacer.
Pero sí en la distribución.
¿Por qué?
Porque no, no estamos sobre te capturando con mi.
Con mi Edit Fills.
Así que voy a hacer clic acá.
Y aquí voy a hacer lo siguiente.
Fíjense acá.
Aquí, si nos damos cuenta.
Voy a borrar esta parte.
parte
y de usted debe estar así ahorita tal cual ya vienen a webbox van a ese anombres
acá abajo de usted dice nombre completo esto lo jalan ahí antes de eso van a
colocar acá doble bar espacio lo jalan esto
costo que no choque ahí lo jalan y les va a aparecer en verdecito eso significa que
ya está bien van a hacer sus demás variables y voy a colocar esto ahora voy a irme al
email igual acá a mí aquí a mí a mí ha detectado pero si usted no se ha detectado igual
barrita significa o y lo jalan subime o correo ahí también
y esto y esto me voy a ahorrar el tercero al celular igual acá aquí fíjense esta
parte los quería explicar voy a mover esto un poco esta partecito fíjense esta parte por
ejemplo dice nul porque hecho nul porque quise es algún dato solamente captura 3
datos por ejemplo en mi en mi formulario estaba 4 datos y en mi edificio está con 4 datos
pero qué pasa si yo me olvidado y coloco solamente tres y hecho montó de trabajos para evitar eso
pueden colocar nul porque están emitidos en valor o les dicen puedes capturar el valor
estos de mi 1 for submission y es de mi juego si no tengo el dato la colocó nul no hay lío pero
si lo tienen no voy a jalar esto y el último mensaje en mensaje igual lo voy a eliminar esta
parte y voy a colocar eso dos barritas y lo jalo el cliente
visto ahí lo dejan ya ahora con eso ya debería de trabajar ahora de nuevo voy a tratar de escuchar
vamos a escucharlo y voy a volver a llenar ya voy a volver a minimizar esto
y vamos a volver a clicar el otro
donde estaba ya de un cachito cada vez lo cierro
no sé dónde está voy a volver a abrir mi contacto
listo ahora sí voy a apartar esto y voy a apartar el otro de mancacho
y bueno aquí lo voy a dividir más en 22 ahora sí seguiremos como está escuchando en este caso
igual coloco lo mismo ya estaba yo voy a colocar tanto listo
y aquí voy a decir dame los quiero hacer un pedido de sus productos
y productos ofrecían
listo apeten enviar y veremos
ya ahí está pensando
ahí está parte aquí en la captura pausa que quiero directamente ya que se pre-entrenen
o ejecutado que la ejecuta directamente ahí está ya está capturando y aquí también lo voy a
pre entrenar listo que se ejecute que vaya pre entrenando sin base ahora el web hook
en lo mejor es la función de manera de golpe ya en algunos como yo tenía que hacerlo para
entrenarlo listo a esperar un poquito ya saben que la primera vez es un poquito tedioso
ya mientras tanto después de las 19 30 voy a pedirles que presenten a cuatro personas su
proyecto con el proyecto de anterior clase era que hagan la conexión mediante su modelo interno
local ya eso va a dar el puntaje y eso voy a registrar base a la sarea listo y lo ejecutaremos
esto yo que me enví ya está ya me enviado voy a abrir mi correo bueno aquí está ahorita
se va a mochar ya está ya me lo lleve ya me he enviado ahí voy a entrar acá y listo ahí está
ya me ha capturado mi nombre lo que le preguntaba qué productos ofrece y está recibido esto
ya listo
en cesa capturita que ustedes han hecho se van a colocar como su captura número 3
listo y ahora sí captura número 3
yo lo tenemos bueno esto ya ya ya podemos trabajar ahora sí con entornos un poquito más
más reales no cuando ya hacemos con html con demás procesos ya podemos trabajar
ahora si quieren hacer un loyin un proceso más de autenticación ya tienen que aplicar
si vas a hacer el dato ya ahora por ese caso ahora digamos que queremos en este caso capturar
los datos del cliente para hacerle para bombardear de google ads para bombardear de promociones para
bombardear de las whatsapp se puede hacer como tendríamos que crear acá otro maya secuela
ya creamos ahora puede colocar insert robin table o sea insertar variados o líneas en tu código
de paso de datos y listo ya eso pero en este caso aquí pueden también hacer clic ya que
voy a colocar es maya secuela y esta parte ya tendría que ser insert yo ya lo conectan
ahí está a la base de que voy a crear acá por ejemplo ya colocarlo inserción de pins
inserción de clíns listo lo voy a cerrar ya ya podemos capturar quien está enviando tal cosa
y puedo obtener más datos se puede mejorar para su edifice para que captura email teléfono su
ip incluso puede hacer que captura para luego bombardear de donde esté y listo así que esa
parte más haremos hoy y vamos a tener a la clase van a presentar sus trabajos ya así que abran su
sam o su post lo que se lo utilizan más pero yo voy a utilizar como se había enseñado el sam ya
voy a habilitar ya no estoy habilitando acá solamente eso si quieren pueden habilitar esto no
iría pero me hecho ya listo y una vez que hagan eso ya saben tienen que habilitar su maya secuela
no es igual y listo voy a ahoritarlo y voy a irme a la ida que estaba previamente trabajando para
que me dé una tabla de datos de inserción de datos ya vengo acá que estaba la y que estábamos
trabajando anteriormente voy a venir a secuel editor voy a venir acá luego enter y aquí voy a colocar
lo que le voy a preguntar a la ida ya vengo acá entonces voy a habilitar uno nuevo de mancachito
donde está ya voy a cerrar mi correo y ahora si aquí no es
vengo acá y voy a entrarme como mod incómodo
y aquí van a colocar todos los datos que quieren capturar así dame una base de datos
en la secuela en la secuela para
para los que con los siguientes para con los siguientes dame una base de datos de una sola
tabla de una sola tabla en ese cuele con los siguientes
listo entonces hago clic y voy a decirle lo que está acá en el web y ya lo que he capturado
acá porque este va a trabajar netamente con esta edad sino este y en base a mis edificios así
que estaba nombre completo si no me equivoco nombre e-mail número de celular y mensaje
ya nombre completo nombre completo nombre a lo más e-mail celular y mensaje
pero mensaje no necesito
quizás si bueno hay mucho de pende quizás yo quiero capturar los mensajes para ver cuál es mi
intinerancia de pedidos es capaz no sé la mayoría de mis clientes me pide en pk como
estoy vendiendo yo en este caso fertilizantes me pide netamente sulfato de potasio nitrato de
potasio ahí sí me serviría lo que es el mensaje más para que luego la ya me haga un análisis de
hasta estadístico ya y listo
y ahí me está creando contactos de b ya que nuestro e-mail celular secundario no es necesario
esto lo voy a borrar los que no necesito y a ustedes pueden aumentar más y demás
lo clickeamos le voy a llevar acá lo voy a pegar y lo que no necesito es todo mi
interés a celular nomás quiero yo fecha de registros y por default va a ser eso así que
voy a crear primero la base de datos agarro la base de datos esto lo voy a minimizar esto
tiene que estar así clickeado luego y los contactos y directamente esto y hasta eso creado
bien venimos acá y esto no habría en el mes o larga mensaje y entonces lo que voy a hacer acá
es de nuevo lo que he hecho anteriormente vengo a mi workflow voy a hacer ahora esto voy a crear acá
voy a llevarlo directamente a mi nueva credencial sería porque voy a hacer con otra credencial
y esta parte ya sabe no es 127.0.0.1 database mail SQL en este caso que era
ya me olvidó su nombre era contactos de be y a contactos
barso a baja de be y o ser voy a colocar lo que ruta
listo pasu lo que tengo en los sistemas tienen pueden colocar listo ya soy listo y hacia
linkeado esto capturó
y eso es su cuarta captura
captura cuarta
y esto locan y esto
ya una vez que lo tengan ya pueden trabajar con parámetros aquí voy a colocar insert
y aquí voy a colocar contactos los va a actualizar no esto
y aquí me pide automap si puedo hacer automapiable pero quiere mape a cada colobre podemos mape a
cada colobre voy a colocar el punto número 2 y aquí voy a añadir los valores ad value y este
value lo van a jalar de acá ya voy a colocar select y value van a colocar el nombre y van a colocar
aquí el nombre
otro valor vienen acá colocan el igual email y le van a signal el email
otro valor acá van a colocarlo en este caso celular y van a jalar los de
y por último el mensaje
y lojala con eso ya estaría
lo cerramos esto
y listo ejecutamos nuevamente
escuchamos y voy a hacer dónde está mi formulario
ahí no lo se rode nuevo
no
lo se rode nuevo si lo se lo lo voy a hacer esto y lo voy a abrir de nuevo
no sé porque tengo la maña de de cerrarlo siempre
ya voy a escuchar y voy a ver
ya así que esta parte donde estaba ahora mi bejo
listo
ya empezaremos entonces voy a minimizar un poco esto
listo ahí
procedemos escuchamos y voy a hacer lo siguiente
ya vamos a colocar Milton
Probably
I know
where you
doing
talking
潮
very
getting
out
hacemos clic y listo
hay que se ejecute, ya saben esta parte pueden trabajarlo así
para que se vaya primero a otro entrenándose
luego hacer la parte producción en el hilo
me faltaba, no le he dado un prompt todavía a mi
a mi mensaje, ya eso es el caso, bueno que termine lo pongo a hacer el mensaje
para que me inserta mi client, porque ahorita no me he hecho eso
voy a venir acá entonces
voy a irme directamente a prompt, el sistema, y voy a hacer
insertame, voy a copiarme esto
inserta los datos capturados
capturados
van a especificar si es posible, porque a veces no entienden
nombre en este caso es celular, perdón nombre y mail
celular
mensaje
se hiron en mi base de datos
que se llamaba ahora, ya no me acuerdo
insurción de clientes, y ahorita los voy a pasar
ahi ya me he hecho olvidar, les tenía que pasar lo apenada
y listo los pasaré el token ya para que vean si no es como lo están haciendo
ahora que me digan, o les fue un ocio en el anterior tocan, creo que lo he eliminado
no se cuanta tokens ya tengo, ahorita voy a ver
listo, así que de banqueteche te los voy a enviar
ya, voy a poner prueba
listo, ya los he enviado, lo estoy enviando ahorita en su
mensaje de mid, haga un prueba con eso
ya los tokens
y con eso son los capturas correspondientes
listo, vayan haciendo eso
yo también hice ya mi insulción cliente, se ve que insulciona mas por el cliente
si vamos a hacer acá
de nuevo mi prompt
los cierro y vuelvo a ejecutar
ya vamos a volver a ejecutar entonces
igual hay que pre entrenarlo, así que de nuevo voy a tratar de hacer esto
de nuevo los he rodado
voy a ver de nuevo esta puerta
listo, contactos
ya lo sé
escucharemos
listo, empezaremos a hacerlo
ya, de nuevo milton
un blanco
ya quiero saber
los productos
listo
ya, ahí esperemos y luego vamos a pre entrenar
pre entrenamos este
listo
ya
ah, ya se porque el dominio de si que estaba, ya vamos a ver esa parte
ya, de nuevo voy a ejecutar
ok, ya te envío el rivero
listo
ya, seguí el roloz en el mío, ahí estoy con un montón de cosas abiertas
ya, los tres unos tendría que dar mal, tendría que dar si o si
ya, porque
no sé si me escuchan pero ahorita estoy con la voz apenas
es que justamente he dado casi 14 horas seguidas de clases
y estoy casi fregado, ya, así que
paciencia chicos, los sábados siempre estoy así, muerto
ya está, ha entrado a lista, ha entrado acá, ya lo que me enví
listo, voy a revisar mi correo, le voy a encochar
ya está mi correo ahora, ya voy a entrar en mi correo
listo, voy a irme acá y los voy a mostrar
ahí los voy a mostrar, ya, ya me han llegado
listo, ahora si, ahí está, ya ha capturado, me da los, todos los
productos que ofrecen y listo, ya
ahora voy a irme a ver mi base datos
voy a actualizarlo, y ahí está, miren
ya se me ha actualizado
y si no se pueden dar cuenta 19.32, 19.30
con 49 segundos, ya, ahí está
esos chicos saquen a captura y deberían de aparecer
los iguales a ustedes
listo, ahí está su quinta captura creo que es
y listo, eso es todo para el por el día de hoy
ahora voy a
corregir sus proyectos
o levante en la mano, quiénes no han hecho así, así que
conscientemente
lo que tienen que ser con su modelo de I a interna de su
oyama, ya, uno
uno, quién más a ver, los demás se pueden que no echen
uno, dos no más, los demás han hecho, ya entonces los demás vamos a
ya, tres, cuatro, parece que es montón era, ya
los demás han hecho, a ver, tampoco Patricia
confiaba en Patricia, qué pasó
listo, ya, entonces vayan avanzando a esa parte chicos
las siguientes, les voy a pedir a las personas, si pueden
bajar sus manos nomás
las siguientes les voy a pedir que sí o si lo tengan en mente
y lo tengan para presentación, y por si acaso la siguiente
semana, el día jueves, netamente media hora ya me van a
presentar sus proyectos, ya el proyecto yo no necesito más que
tu
necesito unas dos planitas que me den su
su proceso, qué van a ser, cómo van a ser y para aquí los
vaya valiendo, ya, no se explaen, o sea trabajen en algo
que puedan cumplir en estas dos, tres semanas que nos queda
no no traten de rayarse, que quiero un montón de softwares
está bien, pero exigian esas estas mismas, pero también cumplen el tiempo
listo, alguien quiere hablar, no hay problema,
alguien quería hablar,
ya, no hay nada entonces, listo chicos, por ahí, las sábadas
vamos a terminar siempre un poquito antes, porque ya no soporto
la garganta, así que esa parte chicos, y los dos
lo voy a recompensar un poquito más de tiempo, ya, pero
y hemos hecho bastante, así que vayan haciendo y vayan generando
sus sistemas para que ya puedan